now Ukrainians go to the polls on Sunday
to choose their next president after a
first-round vote at the end of March the
two remaining candidates are slow to
miss olanski a television star or Petro
poroshenko the incumbent president now
zolensky is the front-runner he won the
first ballot with more than 30 percent
of the vote he is a comedian with no
political experience and he's put
forward very few policy proposals but
his willingness to speak both Ukrainian
and Russian has brought him a lot of
support in the country's mainly
russian-speaking East now Petro
poroshenko is a businessman from the
confectionery industry and he is one of
Ukraine's wealthiest people he was
elected in a snap vote after former
pro-russian President Viktor Yanukovych
was toppled in the 2014 Maidan
revolution his reputation as a reformer
has been damaged his corruption remains
a big problem in Ukraine well let's
bring in our correspondent in Kiev Nick
Connolly for more on this a very unusual
election hi Nick good to see you so a
comedian could become Ukraine's next
president
how has the lansky managed to gather so
much support
good morning sue me well I think you
have to understand all this that
szalinski is someone who's known to
almost all ukrainians he's been at the
top of this country's show business for
the last decade he didn't need to
explain who he was
to anyone but unlike his main
competitors he hasn't been involved in
frontline politics or any politics and
so he's not associated with that baggage
with the disappointments and the
corruption of Ukrainian politics in
recent years so in that sense he had a
kind of clean start he also led a very
positive campaign focused on optimism
something that Petro poroshenko failed
to do instead focusing on kind of a
aggressive war rhetoric with the
conflict with Russia there his critics
would say he's promising all things to
all people he has been pretty slow to
give much in the way of detail of what
he wants to do we were expecting to hear
more on that after the first round but
instead for the last two weeks he seems
to be in doing his best to avoid coming
face-to-face with poroshenko let's have
a look at how those last two weeks
panned out
a sitting president rolling up his
sleeves to give blood for a drugs test
live on TV not something most Ukrainian
voters ever expected to see but see they
did because of this man comedian and
actor Paula Deen was a Lenski president
poroshenko's challenger has turned
ukraine's politics on its head in a
matter of months when zalenski demanded
drug and alcohol tests
poroshenko had little choice but to
agree after picking up just half as many
votes as the Lenski in the first round
poroshenko's had to play catch-up with
his younger rival Kiev's olympic stadium
to capacity 70,000 and the place whether
Lensky says he wants to debate with
Petro poroshenko there's no dusty TV
studio for zalenski who prefers to talk
to his supporters directed her social
media once again Solinsky throwing down
the gauntlet and once again
poroshenko left with no other option but
to agree poroshenko astonished observers
with a late-night reply by video message
if it's the stadium you want yet then so
be it
I'll be waiting for you when poroshenko
travelled to Paris to meet Emanuel
McCall a visit intended to underscore
his diplomatic standing zalenski
again picked him to the post meeting
McCoy and his advisors hours before
poroshenko all the tension in Ukraine
was focused on the mood music between
the presidential candidates and their
French hosts down to the number of
minutes spent at the Alizee palace less
than 48 hours after his return for Paris
Petro poroshenko was walking the turf of
the Olympic Stadium alone with his
supporters is challenged to zalenski to
bring the stadium debate forward had
simply been ignored with his poll
ratings flying high solinsky's
apparently in no mood to compromise
three weeks have now passed since the
first round of voting but Ukrainians are
barely any wiser about what their
presidential candidates plan to do three
weeks debating the how and the when of a
potential debate instead of discussing
the issues of which there are more than
enough in a country locked in standoff
with Russia with more than a million
refugees and millions more leaving the
country in search of work
cilenti's critics argued that's no
coincidence they say as a newcomer to
politics he has little to win and much
to lose debating the detail of being
president today Ukrainians have one last
chance to hear their next president
whoever that will be set out his vision
before they go to the polls
that is if Solinsky important Co can
finally agree on the terms of the debate
Nick you know you said yourself a little
bit earlier that Vladimir Solinsky is
given very little in the way of detail
or policy proposals
so what could Ukraine actually look like
if he were to become president well sue
me he has spoken a lot about fighting
corruption stripping members of
parliament of their immunity as a way of
doing that also
modernizing Ukraine's government systems
digitalization but I think it's really
worth seeing this as more a promise of
generational change an aesthetic change
it's a new generation coming to power in
the way of kind of detailed manifesto
promises we haven't had all too much he
has broadly stayed online with what the
current government is doing on Donbass
saying he's not going to try and solve
that conflict by force also saying he'd
continue Ukraine's cooperation with its
Western lenders I think the interesting
thing will be to see if tonight we do
get that debate and if we hear more
detail from him from what it sounds like
now if they do meet in the Olympic
Stadium they won't be on a single stage
they haven't been able to agree instead
they'll be on separate stages at either
end of the football field make a lot of
people are asking what Russia's role is
in all of this does Moscow have a
preferred candidate here
here's the thing the candidate who
actually traveled to Moscow before the
first round Yuri Boyka something that
had been a common feature of Ukrainian
politics in the past he only came fourth
place I think the war really has changed
the tone here and being seen as too
friendly with Moscow doesn't pay off in
Ukrainian elections but on the other
hand there is a lot of interest in this
election in Russia certainly I think
there is a certain level of exhaust ISM
for Russian observers about elections
that don't have a predestined outcome
Putin's spokesman saying that you'd be
watching these debates if they happen
tonight with poroshenko it's clear that
he is the candidate of the kind of the
cold standoff with Russia he has pitched
its presidency on this volume is a
Lensky by contrast I think has a bit
more wiggle room and a bit more
flexibility to maybe try and shake
things up and talk to you
President Putin a Russia direct in a way
that I think there's no going back for
Petro poroshenko after five years of
this conflict all right Nick Connolly
our correspondent covering the election
in Ukraine for us Nick thank you very
much